hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the one of
the first themes that Epictetus talks
about and the enchiridion which is this
little handbook is figuring out what's
actually in our power and what is not in
our power and if it's not in our power
it's in somebody else's power so it's
about control it's about figuring out
what you actually have some degree of
control over and what you don't but why
would you want to do that why is that
important well if you tie yourself in
with if you invest yourself into things
that you don't actually have any control
over you're setting yourself up to be
very unhappy and he talks about that a
lot of different examples a lot of every
placement but first let's figure out
what it actually is in our control what
actually is in our power so he says some
things are in our control in others now
things in our control are opinion so
wait later on you'll also use the word
judgements pursuit desire aversion so
whether we actually try to do something
or not let's say
choice choices desires conversions
desires you know you're all familiar
with you desire something you walk in
right when you guys came in with stuff
from the cafe and people could smell it
they suddenly now had a desire to to eat
right you've got it why do you have it
because you got to desire to eat
yourself right what's an aversion Thank
You avoid yeah if it's like a desire but
it's in the other direction so it's not
just a desire not to have something you
could think of it like a desire against
something so you wake up in the morning
and it's cold in your room and you don't
want to get out of that it's not that
such as that you have you know you have
no desire to get out of that you
actually your desires pushing you in the
other way stay under the covers right
that's a bottle you have all sorts of
desires and aversions going on all the
time what's not in our control o choices
and actions what's not in our control
according to epictetus yeah yes yeah
disease another bad one that he talks
about is poverty you know you don't have
absolute control over whether you're
going to be rich or poor why do you
start out one way and may end up the
other what else he brings up body looks
property reputation
and he uses this word that gets
translated as command we can think of it
as position rank Authority all those
sorts of things
in a word whatever are not our own
actions whatever is up to other people
or other things so he says the things
that are in our nature are the things
that are in our controller but nature
free unrestrained unhindered those that
are not in our nature are weak slavish
restrained belonging to others what is
it what does he mean by all these easy
adjectives these things you actually
have some degree of control it may feel
to you at this time that you don't like
your for instance your opinions and your
judgments well those are just facts and
there that's just the way the things are
and I can't help but think think of
things this way well if you look at it
more carefully and you do a little bit
of you know self scrutiny and maybe a
little bit of trying out some some new
things and then some self discipline
turns out you actually have a lot of
control over how you think about things
how you view them your attitudes towards
them
your choices in your actions whether
your choices right so you actually do
have control when do we usually say we
don't have a choice you know when we not
happy about what we did but we actually
do them pretty to the Stoics we have
freedom we have choice of our own
actions and then your desires and
aversions that's kind of a strange thing
to say let's use that example again you
know bringing in though let's say I
brought in a pizza right now starting to
eat it from quiet whatever I always use
these food things how do you think I got
this size
yeah you're right it is before lunch
let's say let let's pick something else
besides pizza because you know does that
provoke like a desire on your part
already what would be something okay so
I bring it up up hi yeah I bring on a
puppy yeah you know puppies are cute
right well they're little provided
they're not doing anything they're not
supposed to do and a lot of you would
have a sort of instinctive desire to
come off and pet the puppy right and you
start calling the puppy to come by you
comes by you pick it up you can't cuddle
it some of you might not like it on
these you know weird ain't thinking
about five yeah yeah you're comparing
puppies and - the puppy comes over you
might have an aversion to certain
animals you know let's say you know you
were bitten by a dog that looks just
like this puppy only you know the
puppy's smaller okay now you don't like
that puppy being by you the very thought
that starts to turn you on
do you have any control over that sort
of stuff Epictetus says you do not
necessarily in a direct way it's not
like once you actually have the desire
you just turn it off
but over time you can actually change
your desires you can't change the way
that you feel about things what about
this other side what's not in our power
control now he's not saying that you
don't have any stake in this or you
can't make any you know decisions that
would affect this obviously you you've
managed to keep yourself from dying over
and over again or you wouldn't be in
this classroom and there have been some
instances in which if you if you did
things very carelessly perhaps some of
you could have died but up to this point
I'm going to bet
same thing with disease right all of
your reasonably healthy I think you know
there's things that you could have
chosen that you didn't choose that would
result in you probably being sick
poverty you know you have some degree of
that obviously if you don't work at all
you're going to be probably get before
but here's what he's trying to get at
let's say you say I'm going to go after
these things but not a knocking about
your death you're going to go after the
opposite of that staying alive being
healthy getting out of poverty you say
you're going to go after those things
does that mean you're automatically
going to succeed is it the case and your
experience that those who take the right
precautions it always works out for them
what are they they put in them you know
the work it always turns out good no
yeah the world is not fair ISM and the
same thing goes with a lot of these
things think about your body again a lot
of you are pretty good shape you know as
far as students go on Holi or you know
pretty well dressed you know they're the
good-looking bunch of young adults how
much control do you have over that over
time I mean you have control over what
you wear and I suppose you know if you
want to look better you can undergo
certain procedures and things like that
but you can only do so much with the
body right you've all seen these people
who have had a lot of work done and you
can tell because after a while they
cease to look human they look like
something else
well you know you can only accomplish so
much we're going to say well we're just
going to ask but doesn't your desire for
some of these things don't you have
control over that so I mean sure but
he's talking about the thing itself over
here well like I can see death disease
death body type those are you know
you're destined to die no matter what
happened yet sooner or later you're
destined to die yeah I don't know
anybody who's never ever been sick I can
understand that
yeah adverse poverty we've seen in the
third world where you people you know no
matter what they do no matter how
they try they're never going to get out
of position even here there's there's
generational poverty but some of those
other things I don't know that I can I
could buy into those because I could
change I into in one sense that that we
don't convene I take control of those
things I think that he's not saying [ __ ]
again
he's not saying that you don't have any
stake in it he's saying that despite
what you do they could still go badly so
for instance with your body let's say
you know I decided to lose 50 pounds and
get into shade okay that's a possibility
I mean I get that a little time ago I
could yeah oh so I'm so fine so I can
choose that then I can actually desire
that and I can try to make it happen I
can do that and then you know I can get
hit by the bus next week or I can you
know my knees can go out or all these
sorts of things
same thing with property obviously if
you don't work you're much less likely
to have any property unless you inherit
it but you know your your stuff can get
get damaged the insurance company can
decide not to pay there's a lot of ways
in which things can go wrong his point
is not that we don't have any control
whatsoever
his point is that the degree of control
that we have over these things is much
less than what we have over these same
thing with reputation I mean think about
reputation what is it exists in the eyes
of the others and you I think you've all
had the experience of trying to make
friends with somebody who just did not
want to be friends with you or to try to
you know look a certain way with
somebody who is just going to see the
worst side of you no matter what you
can't control that right you can you can
try as best you can to use all sorts of
techniques but sometimes it just doesn't
pay long position or rank the world fair
with that I mean you guys are going out
into the workplace but I think you've
already experienced quite a bit of that
it's not always the most qualified
person who gets the position it's often
the most connected person right or the
person who just happens to be in the
right place at the right time and now
they're in and that's it so you know
these things we have less control over
and why is he bringing this up he says
think about what desire means desire
following desire promises the attainment
of that was your desiring so if you want
you know your body to be attractive
that's one of your desires if you want
property of a certain sort that's your
desire if you follow that you can't
choose to follow that that's within your
power the zeiger starts promising to you
you're going to have this this is going
to work out go ahead and do this and
it's going to it's going to fall into
your lap a version promises what not
having to endure when you're averse to
so if you act on your versions then that
will happen but the person who fails to
to obtain the object of his desire what
happens to that person are they happy or
unhappy when you want something and you
work to get it and you don't get it how
do you feel yeah yeah yeah there's no
there's a whole range there right
letdown is not that bad depressed that's
a lot worse what else do you feel yeah
yeah anger comes out of being being
disappointed by things by people my
situations frustration is is also in
that range so mainly sadness anger
sometimes it can you can turn people
very better canta when things don't work
out the way they're supposed to I have
colleagues who unfortunately got better
along the way
what about aversion if you if you are
versed of something and you're trying to
avoid it but you fall into it like say
poverty or disease you do your best to
try to avoid disease and you still get
sick and now it's just like a little
sickness you get some sort of you know
terminal illness a glat that sucks right
I mean you should feel bad if that's the
case shouldn't do it and most people
would feel bad and if you look at a
person that doesn't feel bad when that
sort of thing happens you're going to
want to know why because that's so
unusual what could be
stoic good because they don't realize
what they're in what's happened but it
could be because they were stoic so he
says if you actually want to be happy
one of the things you should do is try
to restrain yourself from actually
having desires about these things just
focus on this stuff over here desire
that your desires be of the right kind
desire that your choices and actions be
the right kind whether or not they
actually pay off with all these other
movements I should these aren't good
things the bad things here's the good
things he has some other suggestions
suggestions along these lines he says
you know if you think about some of the
things that we have as possessions that
people invest in it one of the traps if
you're stoic is of identifying yourself
with your possessions and people do this
with say the clothing right for their
cars or their houses somebody comes into
your place and they say you have a
lovely house they're actually saying
something about their hop about your
house they're not saying something about
you you're not a good person because you
have a lovely house you're not a bad
person because you have a lovely house
either it's just an external thing he
has an example of a horse you know not
not to many of us have horses so that's
a little hard to relate to but it says
don't be prideful with any excellence
that's not your own if a horse was
prideful and says I'm handsome
that would make sense right horses
actually talked but if you have a
handsome horse and you're saying you
know I'm really something because I've
got this good-looking horse that's
something that can be taken away from
you in a second
it's not something that's really your
own in the real sense you may have a
deed of purchase but that doesn't make
it your own in a sort of metaphysical
sense he he goes on and he says when it
comes to things in the body
provide things to the body no further
than mere use give yourself food give
yourself drink clothing house
Emily but don't get yourself too
involved in you know having really nice
things because if you do you're going to
start desiring that that's going to
become part of where you're putting your
affection your heart your care and if
you do that you're liable to get hurt
and disappointed but he says you know
the condition of most people is this is
actually what they're looking at they're
not really that focused on this this is
what they do but they're not worried
about having these that right this is
not what I mean you can take pride he
says in having the right opinions of
judgments that would be legitimate you
could actually feel ashamed legitimately
about having the wrong opinions and
judgments or making the wrong choices
for having the wrong desires that makes
sense from from stoic perspective to
have pride or shame about these things
he doesn't think makes much sense
because those are external they're not
really you but he says the ordinary
people expects benefit or hurt from
external things not from themselves
that's what they're setting themselves
up for being being disappointed he says
you may be uncomfortable if you enter
into no combat which is not in your
control to conquer so whenever you see
somebody who's got these nice things who
he says it's eminent and honor or power
high esteem take heed not to be carried
away by appearance and to pronounce that
person happy you don't know whether
they're actually happy or not happiness
for the stoic depends on this stuff over
here and you know this makes perfect
sense I think a lot of you probably know
some people who have a lot of nice
things when it comes to these things
they have a attractive body that's a
shame
they having a lot of nice things people
look up to them you know they get to mix
in the right groups and you
countered them and you find out that
they're really not that happy and why
aren't they happy because they still
desire more things were the things that
they're they desire they get
disappointed with they're not good
enough for them there's a big thing with
bodies I remember this one I used to
actually you know when I wasn't working
out you could go to the gym and you'd
see these guys we would work out
constantly yeah you'd say wow you're in
you know you're a really great shape you
got everything is you know totally cut
and you know you're you know you're not
just doing it for looks
you actually can lift all this weight
and they'd be like yeah that doesn't you
know that's not enough you'd be like wow
you're not happy are you you have a
major self happy because they have this
part that's not really aligned properly
so what would that look like he talks
about this in the discourses he's got
this chapter on improvement and he says
what's the goal here the goal is
actually to attain what he calls
tranquility or peace or satisfaction so
he says what is progress
well you withdraw yourself you withdraw
your desires you withdraw your opinions
and judgments away from external things
you let the external things be what they
are you let the world go on as it is you
don't necessarily try to make it into a
better world or change it except a
little bit that belongs to you you don't
get in everybody else's business pay
attention to your own business you with
Drive yourself from it turn from
externals and you turn to your own will
you turn to your own faculties you turn
to the part of you that's most you you
exercise it you improve it by labor so
as to make it conformable to nature
that's the criterion for the stocks
being in conformity to nature not nature
in the sense of length
the nature Channel or anything like that
but being in accordance with the way we
want to be and we'll talk about that in
a moment
he says if you do that how are you going
to be you're going to be freedom you're
going to be unrestrained unimpeded
you'll be faithful modest and he says if
you you know if you actually tire your
desires in the things that you don't
control you're not going to be free he
says at another point this wouldn't work
we'll sort of people off with this he
says if a person gave your body to any
stranger you met on his way you would be
angry when Jimmy imagine the other
you're back in times and slavery existed
so somebody you know you're walking
along with them with your body anybody
says and let's go in here and you go in
and suddenly now you belong to somebody
else
you got to do what they say you'd be
ticked off with you I hope so Epictetus
thinks that you're doing that with your
mind all the time if you're focusing on
these things and placing your efforts
and your care and your desire over here
then he says you don't feel any shame in
handing over your own mind you'd be
confused and mystified but anybody who
happens to in this case verbally attack
you or he has something that you want if
you want these sort of things or you
want to avoid these sort of things you
have to do a lot of things that you know
place you in other people's power if you
want reputation you have to do what you
got to kiss up to a lot of people don't
you if you want to maintain your
reputation it's not something that you
get once and for all what do you have to
do keep kissing up to people you know if
you want to become you know a celebrity
or something like that you'll have to do
even more of that is that really going
to make you happy probably not if
epictetus is right because what you're
doing is you're placing yourself and
other people's power they have control
over whether you're
what about your body I mean you have
some control over you can work it out
right you can diet you can exercise not
do drugs you know not drink too much
things like that but that doesn't
necessarily mean it's going to turn out
the way you want like I could I could
you know with the body tape that I have
I could never be like a big weightlifter
I'm what you call an endo more if I
actually have believe it or not you know
underneath this should be like a thin
frame not massive muscles if I wanted to
if I wanted to like lift a lot of weight
my bones aren't built for that sort of
thing my joints aren't built for that
sort of thing I'm built for endurance
things some of you are built for that
you know you have that that that is
something that could be a bit you know
something that could happen for you if
you chose to do it but how does it work
with with exercise and dieting and all
that if you do it are you are you
finished once and for all
once you've gotten yourself to that
ideal weight and look and all that sort
of stuff
how long does it take for you to lose
that just now you know nothing bad
happening to you just within action a
month yeah I mean you know if you're
actually working out a lot and you go a
week without working out when you come
back to that workout it hurts doesn't it
because your body gets out of condition
that quick you don't have that much
control over it what about your mind
what about your soul you have control
over that you know you can put patterns
into your mind and your soul that's what
you're doing through education that
lasts you your entire lifetime if you
choose to keep it lock